aucune contamination depuis 17 jours en
nouvelle-zélande
conséquence la levée des mesures de
restriction dès ce mardi dans tout le
pays annonce lundi de la première
ministre salue et mondialement pour son
leadership pendant cette crise
yacine dardenne reste prudente j'ai pu
annoncer que le gouvernement a convenu
que nous passerons maintenant au niveau
1 pour que notre économie est à nouveau
complètement verte
nous sommes convaincus que nous avons
éliminé la transmission du virus en
nouvelle zélande pour l'instant mais
l'élimination n'est pas un point dans le
temps c'est un effort soutenu
nous verrons certainement des cas ici
encore c'est la raison pour laquelle nos
frontières est notre première ligne de
défense
car une vision à ne pas importer le
virus plus de distanciation sociale ou
d'interdiction de se rassembler dès ce
mardi matin les néo-zélandais ont repris
leurs habitudes de vie des citoyens
visiblement satisfait de la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
et nous en sommes tous assez satisfait
je pense que nous avons vraiment bien
réussi en tant que pays à nous
débarrasser de tout cela eh oui je suis
vraiment heureux que nous soyons au
niveau 1
nous voyons certainement beaucoup plus
de monde qu'à la même heure la semaine
dernière est certainement plus qui hier
également ce qui est vraiment excitant
pour nous c'est formidable de retrouver
un sentiment de normalité
fondamentalement pouvoir être dans un
café et retrouver des amis
le confinement et les gestes barrières
étaient mises en place depuis le 25 mars
en plus de ces précautions le
gouvernement avait lancé une vaste
campagne de dépistage plus de 260 mille
tests ont été pratiqués sur la
population
en tout depuis le début de la pandémie
le pays a enregistré un millier de cas
et déplore seulement 22 morts